Olá, sou a Mariana e, como
a Laurinda Alves vos disse,
trabalho na área da educação.
Trabalho na área da educação
e é precisamente na educação
que acredito que podemos
dar o próximo passo
para ficarmos um passo mais à frente
em todos os passos das nossas vidas.
Quando eu tinha 15 anos de idade,
mais ou menos,
vi uma série da televisão inglesa,
chamada "Reviver o Passado em Brideshead",
com o ator Jeremy Irons, que eu adorava.
Essa série inspirou-me imenso.
Os primeiros episódios foram filmados
na Universidade de Oxford.
Vi imagens como esta,
fiquei imediatamente inspirada,
e decidi que queria tentar
ir para lá viver e estudar.
Imagino que aqueles que cresceram
a ver os filmes do Harry Potter,
talvez sintam o mesmo.
O problema era que Oxford era,
e continua a ser,
das entradas universitárias
mais difíceis e competitivas.
Para terem uma ideia, este ano...
Melhor? Muito obrigada.
Dizia que é um pequeno problema
que Oxford é das entradas universitárias
mais difíceis e competitivas
e, para terem uma ideia,
este ano, a Times Higher Education
pôs Oxford em 2.º lugar no mundo,
à frente das Universidades
de Harvard, Stanford, Princeton, etc.
Mas, apesar disso, com uma certa
arrogância própria da juventude,
eu chego lá, aos 17 anos de idade,
com uma certa confiança.
Eu sempre tinha tido ótimas notas,
venho duma família
que sempre favoreceu os estudos,
fui presidente da Associação
de Estudantes na escola,
e, realmente, achei que tinha
tudo para conseguir entrar.
Infelizmente, não foi bem assim,
porque eu rapidamente percebi
que eu, simplesmente,
não tinha as qualidades
de grande parte dos meus rivais,
dos outros candidatos,
e, como devem calcular, não entrei.
Foi um acordar doloroso, mas valioso.
Doloroso porque, como digo, eu achava
que tinha tudo para conseguir entrar
e valioso porque essa experiência,
dura e difícil, abriu-me os olhos
para todo um conjunto de coisas
que eu teria que trabalhar,
todo um caminho
que eu teria que percorrer no futuro,
se eu quisesse estar à altura
dos melhores candidatos.
Tentei seguir por esse caminho
e hoje, passados 16 anos, com 34 anos,
sou, como disse a Laurinda Alves,
uma das entrevistadoras
da admissão em Oxford,
quer dizer que sou eu que ajudo
a escolher alguns dos nossos alunos.
E o que eu quero
partilhar convosco aqui hoje,
são precisamente as qualidades,
as vivências, as competências,
que nós favorizamos em Oxford.
Isto, porque eu acho que
estas qualidades são importantes
não só na Academia, na luta pelas
melhores escolas e universidades,
estágios e empregos,
mas em todos os campos das nossas vidas,
porque estas qualidades podem
fazer-nos pessoas mais capazes,
empenhadas e interessantes.
Estas qualidades resumem-se
a uma coisa muito simples.
Aquilo que eu chamo
de uma "verdadeira educação".
E como já devem ter percebido,
não estou a falar de educação
no sentido normal da palavra,
que é no sentido de educação técnica,
ou da escolarização.
A verdadeira educação
é uma coisa muito mais ampla.
"Nunca deixei que a minha escolarização
"interferisse com a minha educação".
Pois é, eu também não, felizmente,
e Mark Twain já sabia isto no século XIX.
Peço desculpa.
Vou tentar falar agora por aqui.
Perfeito! Obrigada.
Stephen Fry, que é este senhor aqui,
é um escritor humorista e ator inglês
que eu muito admiro nos nossos dias.
Também estudou
numa universidade de topo,
que é a Universidade de Cambridge.
Quando ele descreve essa experiência,
anos mais tarde,
na sua autobiografia,
chega a uma ideia muito próxima
daquela que eu associo
à verdadeira educação:
"A educação é a soma daquilo
que os alunos ensinam uns aos outros
"nos intervalos entre
as palestras e os seminários.
"Sentamo-nos nos quartos uns dos outros
e bebemos café.
"— suponho que hoje
seja vodka e Red Bull —
"e partilhamos entusiasmos,
dizemos grandes disparates
"sobre a política, a religião,
a arte e o universo,
"e depois vamos para a cama,
sozinhos ou acompanhados,
"consoante a vontade de cada um.
"Se não fosse assim, como é que
aprendíamos fosse o que fosse,
"como é que passeávamos
os nossos pensamentos?"
E reparem aqui nas coisas que ele associa
à sua verdadeira educação:
a ideia de que ela é uma coisa que
pode ser transmitida de aluno para aluno,
não só de professor para aluno,
a ideia de ser muito importante
partilhar entusiasmos
e de ter entusiasmos para partilhar,
e também não termos medo
de estarmos errados ou enganados,
dizermos grandes disparates, faz parte.
Esta ideia que nos fica de ser
necessário "passear os pensamentos"
é deliciosa.
E o que é que significa?
Para mim, "passear os pensamentos"
quer dizer que temos
que estar sempre prontos
a termos opiniões sobre
os mais variados assuntos
e também sabermos partilhar,
comunicar, debater
e defender essas opiniões.
E há todo um treino
que nos pode ajudar nisto.
Nas escolas e universidades inglesas
existem clubes de debate.
Um clube de debate é exatamente
a mesma coisa do que um clube de futebol.
exceto que, em vez de
passarmos a bola uns para os outros,
passamos pensamentos,
ideias e argumentos.
Eu já assisti a algumas sessões de treino.
Tipicamente, um aluno mais velho
ou um professor
senta-se à cabeceira da mesa,
com três alunos do lado esquerdo,
três alunos do lado direito.
Os alunos do lado esquerdo têm que ser
a favor do tema que é proposto
e os do lado direito têm que ser
contra esse mesmo tema,
e têm que defender essa posição,
imediatamente, sem preparação nenhuma,
com bons argumentos, convicção e,
se possível, algum sentido de humor.
O tema pode ser qualquer coisa.
Pode ser um tema que tenha a ver
com a atualidade, por exemplo:
"O TEDxAveiro é o melhor evento do ano".
Mas este é um mau exemplo, porque
é uma posição que só é possível defender.
(Risos)
Ou então, pode ser uma coisa mais
filosófica, sem resposta possível, como:
"É melhor ser alegre do que ser triste".
E aqui o que interessa é pensarmos
imediatamente em voz alta:
"O que é que isso quer dizer?
O que é a felicidade?
"Será que é melhor?
Melhor para quem?
"Melhor para mim?
Melhor para os outros? Etc."
Os alunos mais ambiciosos de Oxford,
que saíam destes clubes de debate,
viriam a debater contra políticos,
economistas e jornalistas
na Oxford Union,
que é uma espécie de câmara
de deputados em ponto pequeno.
Eu tive imensa pena de
não ter tido isso na minha escola
quando era mais nova
e, se pudesse voltar atrás, o que eu fazia
era criar um desses clubes
com os meus amigos
porque a comunicação é uma vantagem
enorme, enorme para toda a vida.
Eu teria menos medo
de estar aqui a falar hoje.
Mas sei que já existem
esses clubes aqui em Portugal.
Aliás, hoje ao almoço, alguém me contou
que existe uma coisa que se chama
a Toastmasters
que dá exatamente este treino
e funciona também aqui em Aveiro
e recomendo vivamente que procurem
a Toastmasters ou clubes do género.
Felizmente, nunca é tarde demais
para aprendermos.
Aliás, essa é outra mensagem
que eu vos quero deixar aqui hoje.
Gandhi, que sempre é tido como sendo
muito mais sábio do que todos nós,
um guru, diz:
"Viva como se fosse morrer amanhã.
"Aprenda como se fosse viver para sempre".
E felizmente hoje temos
o mundo inteiro na ponta dos dedos.
Há recursos incríveis
que nos ajudam a aprender,
como se fôssemos viver para sempre.
Estou a pensar nos livros e na Internet.
Uma pessoa na Índia, agora, pode assistir
a palestras, seminários
e cursos inteiros "online",
da Universidade de Oxford,
ou de Yale ou de Harvard.
Eu acho que isto é
a democratização da educação,
é um fenómeno que me comove imenso.
Acho mesmo que é
dos eventos mais importantes
a que eu já assisti na minha vida.
Um recurso muito interessante
neste sentido
é uma aplicação chamada ITunes U,
que é uma aplicação de onde podemos
descarregar estes conteúdos universitários
em vez de músicas ou filmes.
Também recomendo vivamente
que descarreguem essa aplicação
para os vossos Smartphones.
Já vimos que todos têm
um Smartphone aqui.
(Risos)
E para terem uma ideia,
a página de Oxford na ITunes U
foi criada há cinco anos,
e tem hoje 20 milhões de visualizações.
Vinte milhões de visualizações!
Quer dizer que esta fome
pela verdadeira educação existe.
Hoje em dia, porque
quero sair de casa às vezes,
para não ficar sempre agarrada
ao computador e aos livros,
também tento ir a palestras, tertúlias
e vir a eventos como este.
Acho que é importante procurarmos
a verdadeira educação de forma ativa
e estão todos de parabéns por estarem aqui
porque já estão um passo à frente,
só por terem vindo.
A educação também passa
por procurarmos novas experiências,
para além de novos interesses
e pontos de vista.
Em Inglaterra, muitos ingleses
tiram um ano sabático
entre a escola e a universidade,
mas não passam esse ano inteiro
sem fazer nada, na praia a apanhar sol,
até porque não há muito sol em Inglaterra.
Em vez disso, o que eles fazem
é procurar novos desafios,
umas viagens incríveis
que fazem muitas vezes sozinhos,
com pouco dinheiro
ou com o pouco dinheiro
que conseguem através de patrocínios.
Um amigo meu, por exemplo,
foi ensinar inglês, durante seis meses,
para um mosteiro no Tibete,
durante o ano sabático.
Nessa altura, ele era o único estrangeiro.
O meu amigo é o único que
não está vestido de encarnado.
(Risos)
Ele partiu para essa aventura,
a achar que ia ser uma experiência gira,
um novo desafio, sem dúvida,
mas sem grandes consequências
para a sua vida.
Mas acontece que essa viagem,
por acaso, mudou a sua vida,
porque ele gostou tanto
do Tibete e da sua cultura
que começou a estudar
esses assuntos e nunca mais parou.
É hoje um dos grandes especialistas.
Indo em busca duma nova aventura,
acabou por descobrir
aquilo que realmente o realiza.
E, aqui em Portugal, também sei
que cada vez mais pessoas
procuram este tipo
de viagens e experiências.
Também há ótimos recursos
que nos podem ajudar a organizá-las.
Existe, por exemplo, a Gap Year Portugal,
um recurso valiosíssimo.
Estas viagens não são só para estudantes.
É claro que, mais à frente,
pode ser mais difícil termos
disponibilidade e vontade,
mas não é completamente impossível.
Muitas vezes estas experiências
podem ser tão transformadoras
que são a faísca necessária
para uma mudança
de carreira ou de percurso.
Outra vertente da verdadeira educação,
que eu não posso deixar de referir,
é a nossa participação na sociedade,
o nosso compromisso social.
Há duas semanas, tive a sorte
de poder assistir a uma palestra
de Matthieu Ricard, em Lisboa.
Matthieu Ricard é um filósofo francês
e também monge budista
que começa agora a estudar
os efeitos no nosso cérebro,
com a ajuda de neurocientistas,
do altruísmo, pela preocupação
e pelo trabalho com o próximo,
o trabalho de voluntariado.
O que está a descobrir
— e isto está provado cientificamente —
é que o altruísmo
e o trabalho de voluntariado
nos fazem a nós mais felizes.
Está provado cientificamente.
Para além disso, quando nos envolvemos
com o mundo à nossa volta
fazendo trabalho de voluntariado,
também ficamos mais plenos,
mais completos.
Todos ganham. É o que os ingleses
chamam uma situação "win-win" total.
Todos ganham com isso.
É por isso que o compromisso social
e o trabalho de voluntariado
são coisas tão valorizadas em Oxford
e também cada vez mais
pelas boas empresas.
Nos Estados Unidos da América,
muitas empresas privadas
dão uma semana inteira de férias
aos seus colaboradores, todos os anos,
para que possam fazer
trabalho de voluntariado,
e continuam a pagar os salários
durante essa semana.
Para concluir, daquilo que eu aprendi,
ao longo do meu percurso,
e daquilo que se vive hoje em dia,
ao nível da educação ao mais alto nível,
a verdadeira educação
está ao alcance de todos.
Ela passa, a meu ver,
por estes tópicos que eu aqui passei.
Primeiro, para aprendermos
a passear os pensamentos,
temos que aprender a pensar,
a debater, a partilhar.
Nas entrevistas de admissão em Oxford,
eu não estou minimamente interessada
em saber o que um aluno,
um candidato, já sabe.
Eu quero tentar perceber
como é que ele pensa,
se ele realmente se interessa
pelos mais variados assuntos
e sabe ir à procura
da verdadeira educação, por ele.
A verdadeira educação passa também
por aprofundar os interesses que já temos
e explorarmos novos interesses,
procurarmos experiências novas
e, finalmente, pelo compromisso social.
Como portuguesa que trabalha em Oxford,
ainda mais estando aqui,
noutra grande cidade universitária,
devo dizer que acredito mesmo que
investirmos todos na verdadeira educação
— e, quando digo todos,
quero dizer cada um de nós,
mais as nossas escolas, mais
as nossas universidades e professores,
mais as nossas empresas e o nosso país —
é aquilo que nos pode pôr
um passo à frente
para todos os próximos passos.
Obrigada.
(Aplausos)